يصادف هذا الأسبوع أحد هذه
الذكرى السنوية المهمة حقًا ، لقد
مر عام منذ أن أعلن عن هذا
وباءً ، لقد
مر عام منذ فرض القيود ،
وأتصور أنك لم تمر
أبدًا بعام مثل هذا ، ما هو
أهم شيء بالنسبة لك  لقد
تعلمت
جيدًا ، أعني الكثير من الأشياء المهمة ،
لكن أحدها هو
القدرة غير
العادية لهذا الفيروس على القيام بأشياء
لم تكن لتتوقعها ، أعني
إذا كنت قد رجعت عقارب الساعة إلى الوراء عامًا واحدًا
وعندما كان لدينا  إن قرار
إغلاق السفر من أوروبا الذي
كان قبل عام غدًا في
11 مارس 2 لم يكن ليتخيل أبدًا
على الرغم من أنني مررت
بفاشيات متعددة لأمراض مختلفة
، وكان يعتقد أنه سيكون لديك 525000
شخص في أمريكا  مات
وعنك تعلم أن 28 مليون إصابة
في هذا البلد
كان من المستحيل تخيلها حقًا ،
لذا فإن هذا الفيروس هو عدو هائل جدًا
إذا كنت تريد أن تكون مجازيًا
بشأنه  فقط غير عادي
وما زال أه وما زلنا على وشك
المضي قدمًا ، أعتقد أن
الأمور تسير بشكل أفضل في
الاتجاه الصحيح خاصة
بسبب التقدم العلمي الذي سمح
لنا الآن بالحصول على
العديد من اللقاحات عالية الفعالية
ولكننا لم نفد من  حتى الآن على
الرغم من أننا نريد حقًا أن نكون ونحن
نسير في هذا الاتجاه ، ولكن إذا نظرت
الآن
حتى كل يوم على الرغم من أن
العدوى تنخفض ،
فهذا نوع من الهضبة قليلاً مما
يعطي القليل من القلق هناك ، نأمل
أن يكون ذلك  يستمر
في النزول ولكن انحراف
المنحنى
الذي كان ينخفض بشكل حاد بد
الآن في الاستقرار قليلاً ، لذلك علينا أن
راقب ذلك ، وهذا لا يعني أن
تشعر بالإحباط الشديد حيال ذلك ، اس
مر في السير في الاتجاه ال
حيح  استمر في اتخاذ خطوة بخطوة نحو
شكل من أشكال الحياة الطبيعية ولكن يجب أن يكون الأمر
بطيئًا وحكيمًا.
احصل على فكرة جيدة عندما
ترى أن العدوى تستمر في الانخفاض
يومًا بعد يوم يومًا بعد يوم
تتزايد أعدادها في
نفس الوقت مع الجانب الآخر
من العملة
حيث يتم تطعيم المزيد والمزيد من الناس